Усі вони дуже різні, але намір у них один: стати на захист України.
Це - майбутні військові ЗСУ, які лише вчаться бути солдатами.
Тримаю дах! Тримаю двері!
За помилки отримують порцію критики від інструктора...
Ви кути зайняли? Криєте кути чи що?
Тим не менше дуже стараються, прагнучи бути корисними для країни.
Я не боюсь. Мені нема чого боятися.
Це - Нікіта. Початок повномасштабного вторгнення зустрів 16-річним підлітком.
Тепер, через 2 роки, щойно йому виповнилося вісімнадцять - розпочав процес вступу до ЗСУ.
Коли почалося повномасштабне вторгнення, то мені було 16 років.
Я поїхав з мамою в Польщу до свого вітчима. І потім, коли мені вже було 17 років,
через три-чотири місяці мені мало бути 18, я приїхав вже до України.
Побув трохи в Україні, виповнилося мені 18 років - і я сюди прийшов.
Ідеться про Третю штурмову бригаду, до якої Нікіта хоче потрапити шляхом рекрутингу.
У широкому розумінні, рекрутинг - це підбір персоналу на певну вакансію.
Військовий рекрутинг передбачає той самий процес, але кандидатів шукають
на конкретні посади у батальйони, підрозділи і військові частини.
Тобто рекрутинг дає можливість самостійно обрати посаду в ЗСУ.
У Збройних силах, взагалі в Силах оборони, потрібні мотивовані люди.
Тобто людину не просто так притягнути й змусити щось робити.
Вона повинна свідомо підійти до цього вибору, знайти себе й там себе проявити -
з огляду на власне бачення і потреби держави.
Є прогнозованість і зрозумілість процесу: куди я йду служити,
де я буду служити, з ким, хто буде моїм командиром, хто буде моїми товаришами,
як буде враховано мій досвід. Власне, щоб людина хоч якось впливала на свою долю в армії.
Проєкт з рекрутингу до лав ЗСУ стартував торік у листопаді.
Тоді міністерство оборони почало співпрацювати з популярними
онлайн-сервісами для пошуку роботи.
Вони проходять шлях реєстрації, вносять про себе дані й вносять вакансії,
які у них є на цей час.
Ми є ось цим майданчиком. Ми їх зі свого боку перевіряємо й надаємо їм
абсолютно безкоштовний пакет послуг на розміщення таких вакансій.
Наша участь у цьому як сервісу завершується. Після цього шукачі заходять,
відгукуються на вакансії, рекрутери з військової частини беруть
й опрацьовують ці відгуки і вже працюють напряму з людьми, які звернулися.
Вакансії можна знайти не лише на онлайн-сервісах з працевлаштування,
а й на офіційних сайтах конкретних бригад чи підрозділів.
Приміром, так зробив Нікіта, який чітко вирішив: до ТЦК не піде,
адже хоче самостійно вирішувати, де служити у війську.
Тож хлопець відгукнувся на вакансію на сайті Третьої штурмової,
успішно пройшов співбесіду й ось - він уже на навчаннях зі зброєю в руках.
Контракт із ним укладуть лише після успішно пройденої підготовки
з тактики, медицини і мінно-вибухової справи.
Мій брат пішов воювати через військкомат, і сталася дуже неприємна ситуація:
його позиції "здали", він отримав дуже серйозне поранення.
Тому що він пішов через військкомат, а там командування… ну, таке собі.
У нас тут не працює так, як в ТЦК. У нас спочатку йде навчання.
Поки не побачать, що ти навчився, поки не побачать, що твоя група вже повністю
злагоджено може працювати, розуміє, що треба робити, як треба робити, -
до того моменту нас не відправлять на фронт. А так нас не кинуть на "м'ясо".
Саме можливість обрати своє місце в армії, а також недовіра до ТЦК
є основними причинами, чому дедалі більше українців долучаються
до лав ЗСУ через рекрутинг.
Станом на сьогодні ми маємо більш ніж 70 тисяч відгуків за цей час
на приблизно 5 тисяч вакансій. І станом на сьогодні близько восьми сотень
різних підрозділів Сил оборони долучені до цією діяльності,
тобто розміщують свої вакансії на онлайн-платформах.
Скільком охочим вдалося працевлаштуватися до війська завдяки рекрутингу -
інформація засекречена, доступ до неї має лише Генштаб.
Утім, представники онлайн-сервісів стверджують: попит чималий.
На окремі позиції - десятки претендентів. Приміром, на Work.ua
серед українців найпопулярнішими є такі вакансії у війську,
як бухгалтер, водій, діловод, стрілець, оператор БПЛА та кухар.
Що потрібно найбільше війську? Це і водії, і стрільці, і оператори БПЛА,
і бойові медики, й з топ-5 у нас цього тижня снайпери.
Здебільшого найшвидше "закриваються" небойові посади.
А ось, приміром, охочих податися на вакансію "штурмовик" - не так багато.
Проте Нікіта хоче саме на передову і готується штурмувати ворога "на нулі".
Хочу потрапити в "пекло". Не сидіти десь на першій, другій, третій лініях, не ховатися,
а боротися з противником в максимально близькому контакті.
Рекрутів навчають справжні професіонали. Приміром, відпрацюванням зачистки будівлі
керує Дмитро Усіченко, більш відомий як "Вишня".
Військовий пройшов полон і був одним із небагатьох, кому вдалося
дістатися до заблокованої "Азовсталі" на гвинтокрилі.
Згуртованість - їм це треба дати. Бо вони зараз трохи розрізнені.
Багато людей молодих, амбітних, але я гадаю, що у них все вийде.
Утім, рекрутинг не замінить загальної мобілізації, наголошують в міноборони.
Мобілізаційні заходи тривають й тривати будуть.
Держава, у громадян якої є конституційний обов'язок її захищати, дивиться,
які це громадяни, встановлює їхній стан здоров'я, фах тощо й залучає їх
до служби без врахування… Із врахуванням, звісно, коли це можливо,
але базово без врахування їхніх побажань.
А ось якщо ти свідомо підходиш, то в тебе є можливість вибору.
І це тоді для тебе контрольований процес.
Ти йдеш туди, куди висловив бажання, куди підійшов, і ти розумієш,
що з тобою там буде відбуватися.
Тож, у міноборони кажуть: рекрутинг у військо розвиватимуть далі.
Наприкінці березня має розпати роботу Державна агенція з рекрутингу "Свідомо",
яка інформуватиме українців про нові можливості й допомагатиме
з працевлаштуванням до війська.